[Musique]
en quelques années facebook et twitter
ont complètement modifié les débats de
société
tout le monde a désormais voix au
chapitre et les adolescentes se font
aussi entendre on les a vus par exemple
utiliser la puissance des réseaux
sociaux pour dénoncer les injustices
vécues dans leur milieu scolaire
plusieurs petits scandales comme des
codes vestimentaires quotidien jugée
sexiste ou des règlements pour le bal de
fin d'année considérer rétrograde ont
été étalées au grand jour des
publications pour adolescentes autrefois
plutôt consensuel emboîtent le pas le
teen vogue par exemple qui proposait
jadis des pages de mode des quizz
psycho-pop des trucs beauté et des
entrevues avec des vedettes leur parle
aujourd'hui de politique et le féminisme
on pense aussi au magazine féministe
comme shameless qui ont réorienté leurs
contenus et s'attaquent maintenant non
seulement aux questions de genre mais
aussi de race de classe et de personne
handicapée
on vise même le tout jeune fille avec de
nouveaux magazines comme casu qui s'est
fait connaître en 2016 avec une campagne
de sociaux financement et qui souhaite
inspirer les filles de 5 à 10 ans à être
forte intelligente et 50